يقدم الجيش الإسرائيلي مزيدًا من
التفاصيل حول
سبب قصفه وتدميره لمبنى
في غزة كان يستضيف
مكاتب الصحافة المرتبطة وقناة الجزيرة
خلال ذلك الصراع الذي استمر 11 يومًا
مع مسلحين بقيادة حماس الشهر الماضي الآن
وفقًا للجيش الإسرائيلي كان حماس.
استخدام المبنى المعروف باسم
مبنى الجالا
لتطوير قدرات جديدة قالوا
إنها يمكن أن تشوش إلكترونياً
على نظام القبة الحديدية للدفاع الصاروخي لإسرائيل ،
وهو النظام الذي
يعترض الصواريخ في الجو
قبل أن تتمكن من الهبوط في مناطق مدنية
أعطتها القوات الجوية الإسرائيلية لشاغليها.
تم إخطار المبنى قبل ساعة من
إخلاء المبنى قبل قصف المبنى
مما أدى إلى
انهياره ووفقًا للجيش الإسرائيلي
يقولون إن الهدف كان ذا
قيمة عسكرية كبيرة لحماس وأن
المعدات كانت
في المبنى وقت
قصفه و  انهار المبنى
لكن هذه الخطوة قوبلت بإدانة واسعة من قبل
المنظمات الإخبارية والمنظمات
الصحفية الدولية
التي وصفتها بالأمم المتحدة  مقبولة وتشكل
تهديدا لحرية الصحافة
التقى السفير الإسرائيلي لدى الولايات المتحدة غيلاد أردوغان يوم الاثنين مع
القيادة في نيويورك قال
لمحاولة إعادة العلاقة
وإعطاء هذه المعلومات وقال
إن إسرائيل لا تعتقد أن
علمت الصحافة المرتبطة أن حماس ربما كانت تعمل
خارج
المبنى ، وتقول AP أنه ليس لديها ما يشير إلى
أن حماس كانت تعمل خارج
المبنى ودعت مرارًا وتكرارًا إلى
تحقيق مستقل حتى يتم التعرف على
الحقائق بالكامل
hadas gold cnn jerusalem